we need to  significantly reduce the numbers of  people crossing the channel the Prime  Minister has been absolutely clear I've  been absolutely clear the legal  migration particularly in the numbers  that we've been seeing more recently is  totally unacceptable what's important is  that in order to solve the problem of  illegal migration on the channel we take  a  multi-dimensional approach there's no  single answer there's no quick fix  there's no Silver Bullet our Corporation  and collaboration with the French on the  channel on the UK Coastline on the  French coastline is absolutely integral  to ensuring that there is a a robust  barrier preventing people disembarking  from the French beaches in the first  place